thank you so much indeed uh for joining
me today it's very timely you're here in
Las Vegas for the annual Republican
Jewish Coalition and they're one of the
most important voices in the American
Republican party you just came off stage
you made a blistering speech there's no
two ways about that this was fullon
Hardcore
pro-israel and it's come at a moment
when many people are going the other way
the ground Invasion has started as many
more thousands of Palestinians are
getting killed as other people are
perhaps beginning to wobble with their
support for Israel you've hardened yours
why well it's interesting you say that
pierce because I've just taken criticism
in the other direction as well so before
yeah well well even even from today's
speech really it's the point is it's a
little bit different than what anybody
else is saying on one hand and this is
the core of my message today I support
Israel's right to national self defense
it is an absolute right and Israel
should be free to pursue whatever
solution Israel wants to pursue that is
their judgment to make without a second
guessing them on the other hand I
believe that that is Israel's decision
to make and Israel's mission to carry
out and the scope of the US involvement
in this needs to be providing diplomatic
cover a diplomatic Iron Dome as I call
it for Israel to carry that out but at
the same time without military
engagement so there are voices in
multiple different camps that have
criticisms of some element of what I've
said many in the neocon movement in the
United States or the old neocon movement
would say that I should unapologetically
unabashedly support US military
engagement I don't I'm an America First
conservative but I also support Israel
pursuing an Israel first agenda and I
think that if we in the United States go
back to our founding ideals I quoted
George Washington's farewell speech
where he warned against unnecessary
foreign entanglements but also go back
to David boran's vision for Israel
that's really the true strength of the
US Israel relationship is when it's
grounded in the self-interest of each
nation in that honesty and so yes I I'm
a little bit different than traditional
politicians but that's where I come out
I want to read I want to be precise
about it because I was as I was waiting
to interview you I was looking at your
tweets uh today actually about Israel
and it just seemed to me and correct me
if I'm wrong but it seemed to me youd
suddenly decided uh to take a much more
direct and tough position and he said
this now is the moment for Israel to
return to its founding premise the
Jewish state has an absolute right to
exist a Divine gift gifted to a Divine
Nation charged with a Divine Purpose
Israel has an absolute unequivocal right
and responsibility to defend itself to
the fullest applying the only language
its adversaries understand the language
of force and what would David benguan
say don't depend on anyone else's
fleeting sympathies or permission to do
it if Israel wants to destroy herass
Israel should go ahead and Destroy
herass if Israel wants to destroy hisbah
hisbah if Israel and mosa want to pull
off Munich 2.0 and take out every last
leader of Hamas whether they're hiding
from Doha to Dresden and host a red
wedding at the Four Seasons in Qatar
they should go ahead and do it now when
I read that I was I was a bit taken
aback because your rhetoric about Israel
I would say before all this back in the
summer was not as strident as this well
this in the wake of an attack what I'm
saying is the principle the same the US
should not be involved but when the US
is not involved I think that's better
for the US it's also better for Israel
to be able to here here's the question
I'm going to ask you it's it sounds to
me like your support for Israel is they
can do what the hell they like yes but
you want to be president of the United
States and there are many people in
America you know this who are extremely
concerned about the proportionate scale
of the Israeli response already and it's
only likely to get a lot worse before
anything is resolved here is your
support for them unconditional because
it sounds like it is my support for
their right to National self-existence
and self-defense and carrying out
whatever the heck they think is
appropriate in response to the attack
submitted on them yes it is not our job
to get involved in this in One Direction
or another but it is the American
president's job actually to get involved
in all these things because America I I
I don't think so actually and that's
where I differ from people in both let
me let me rephrase it historically it's
been America's position in the world to
be leader of the Free World to be almost
the world's Global
policeman and it sounds to me if you
were to become president what you're
saying is any country can in interest of
its own self-defense can do what the
hell it likes and you won't condemn it
is is there no limit to that well look I
think that within the bounds of
following international law right within
the bounds of the legal framework that
we all abide by yes it's not our job to
be the global policeman and I think
there's a lot to what you said there
Pierce that's true the historically
especially if you look at the last 25 30
40 years that has been the role of the
United States is to try to play this
role of global cop well I'm running for
president of the United States of
America and my job as the US president
is to look after American interests
that's a shift from The neoconservative
View it's a shift from the model of
liberal hegemony and I think part of
this is because I come from a different
generation that has seen the costs of 6
and5 trillion dollars of our national
debt attributable to the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan that did not Advance us
interests thousands upon thousands of
innocent lives sacrificed in those two
Wars alone yes I grew up into a
generation where we saw that I reject
that Vision but that means we have to
practice what we preach in all
directions that means this is Israel's
right to defend itself they should be un
constrained and unrestrained the IDF can
I believe get its own job done for those
who would call for US military
involvement I say no my view to Iran is
you stay out and we stay out and that's
something that'll keep Iran out and we
stay out of it as well but that's a
different view also than saying that
then I'm somehow going to second guess
what decisions Israel makes no Israel
has a right to National self-defense and
we're not going to police them but the
United States sends a lot of money to
Israel every year you in the summer
indicated you didn't say categorically
and I know you've been misrepresented in
some of the language that people have
used about what you did say but you
certainly suggested that by 2028 you'd
like Israel to be autonomous from
American Investment I said it would be a
good destination if we did get there I
personally think this will be better
both for Israel and for the United
States if that's a destination we're
able to get to now to be clear from a US
standpoint pragmatically speaking I've
said that we will not cut off Aid to
Israel that annual aid until Israel says
they're ready for it but actually go
back and look at BB's speech to Congress
and 1996 he said that we have reached
something like the end of our infancy
and it is time for Israel to stand on
our two feet that's approximately what
he said in 96 BB's running Israel today
but until America stops sending the
money America does have a vested
interest in what Israel does well I
think that's a product of prior
commitments but my view is the $16
billion we here well as we sit here the
$16 billion doar that Congress is
debating now most Republicans favor it
most many democrats favor it I don't I
say this $6 billion Aid package forget
about it we have a $33 trillion national
debt crisis in this country a border
crisis in the United States of historic
proportions my job as the US president
is to deal with that right here at home
and yes I stand for Israel's right to
absolutely pursue its National
self-defense you don't want to help them
not militarily diplomatically I do
diplomatically standing for their right
to do it I
thinku and he's coming under lot of far
himself but he would probably say well
hang on what does that mean you're going
to put this Iron Dome diplomatically
around us we yes the UN look at with the
Secretary General the he say we've
always relied on America to be there for
us militarily to be there for us
financially you've we are there
financially as I said We Stand by one of
our greatest allies well as you noted I
stand by our commitments we have $3.8
billion in Aid that's going to Israel I
don't propose cutting that off we've
made that 10year commitment for a reason
but I think actually I'm not sure that
that's exactly what BB would say mean I
gave you what BB has addressed to
Congress was in 1996 to also call out
the unspoken truth here appears one
unspoken truth of those carrier groups
going to the conflict area part of the
reason they're there is also to keep
play Big Brother to Israel to sort of
say what Israel can and can't do so I
say go back to David Ben grian's
founding vision for Israel that's what I
would tell B you do what you need to do
okay but I would say to you the reason
actually those carriers have been sent
in is because because it is absolutely
in America's national interest what
happens now in this war because if
things were to escalate and just before
I sat down with you I saw a statement
from the the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
extremely censorious demanding an
immediate ceasefire saying that they
think this this could be a disaster for
the region you've got president erdogan
of Turkey calling Israel of early war
criminals now in a at a rally in in
Turkey this is really escalating fast so
I think we need to deescalate it and I
don't think our military presence there
help I'm I'm going to come to how that
may or may not transpire but the idea
that this is not relevant or pertinent
to America's national interest is for
the birds isn't it well I'm not saying
that it's not relevant or pertinent
what's happening in the world my
question is does our military engagement
help our national interests and that's a
different question what about the number
of little attacks we're seeing on
American troops all around exactly
proves my point why do we have troops in
Syria why do we have troops in Iraq we
were told the American public yes most
people before this began in the last two
weeks they would tell you we don't even
have a presence in Syria and Iraq that's
what we've been led to believe so we
have Sitting targets and now we're going
to create more sitting targets what are
those sitting targets when they're hit
they're accidental trip wires that's how
major conflicts result when nobody on
either side of that conflict has an
interest in getting into it so I worry
when you have a loose network of even
Loosely Affiliated Renegade ban groups
Islamic terrorist groups that are only
not even centrally managed in any way
you cross a trip wire and my rule of
thumb for the us as our
commander-in-chief I'll say it now I'll
say it again if you hit us we will hit
you back 10 times harder that's just a
rule I'll stick to but if they're
hitting us on bases that we shouldn't
have been in in the first place we're
creating the opportunities for
escalation into larger scale Regional
war that doesn't Advance our so I would
bring them home Syria and Iraq but
America has kept troops at a lot of
bases around that region I'd get them
out really yes because the whole purpose
of them being there is to try and
maintain some sort of order amid a lot
of potential chaos and I think it's been
unsuccessful I mean even if you look at
right now the fact that we have that
presence I'm going to stick specifically
to Syria and Iraq let's be precise I
don't think that that has serves any
strategic purpose to the contrary it
creates Sitting Duck Targets in moments
like these that unnecessarily create
trip wires for major regional conflict
in the Middle East and so nobody has
given me a good answer and it's I don't
think nobody's given the American people
a good answer on why the heck we are
still in Syria and Iraq we shouldn't be
there's no strategic interested issue
there it's strictly downside risk
especially in times of emotional
response like this it's a bad idea all
the way down so I stand by that
principle now I'm not some sort of
pacifist isolationist for the sake of
being an idealogue about it no I look at
every individual region of the world
every theater through the lens of
American self-interest and I worry
appears the ultimate winner in this is
actually going to be China watching us
if we are mired in another large scale
Regional prolonged no- win war in the
Middle East China's the beneficiary of
that and you look at the amount of
Munitions we've given to Ukraine about
10 1.5 million rounds of artillery now
we're producing about 20 to 40,000 per
month in the US closer to 20,000 in fact
it was not that long ago that 300,000 of
those rounds that we held in Israel were
sent to Ukraine so this isn't an endless
cycle or a pot that runs infinitely deep
the foundation of war is economics
actually and our economic and industrial
base does not have it in it relative to
even other points in our national
history for us to be able to opt into
multiple of these conflicts at the same
time as US president as the
commander-in-chief when it comes to war
my principle is simple war and our
involvement in it is never a preference
it would only ever be a necessity but I
worry that many of the steps that we're
taking the people here are taking in the
United States of America are
sleepwalking us into World War III at a
time where we can't afford it the United
Nations uh voted a motion for
ceasefire in this war the United States
voted against that motion the United
Kingdom my country abstained where do
you sit on that I think the United
Nations has outlived its purpose I
really think that the statements that
Secretary General gutterz met made I
think on Wednesday this week were
offensive they were senseless in nature
trying to draw false equivalence between
Israel's Behavior versus the Hamas
attacks on Israel that false equivalence
is everything you might if I see it from
a 19-year-old freshman at Harvard
College I call the kid lost and hungry
in search of purpose and meaning but to
see this from the Secretary General of
the UN that's toxic I personally think
that we should have an open conversation
about the US's continued involvement in
the UN I don't think that that should be
a foregone conclusion really if you
think about a body whose Human Rights
Council is staffed by the rights of
Venezuela and North Korea it's a farce
it doesn't serve an actual ual coherent
purpose and so this is just gz's
statements in the last week are just he
said he an institution that's outlived
its purpose he said it's important to
recognize that masses attacks didn't
happen in a vacuum and Palestinians have
been subjected to five Decades of
suffocating occupation now I agree with
the criticism that it was very badly
worded because he was trying to imply
that somehow the isra Israel the timing
of that versus him saying that six
months ago different two different
conversations his yeah but on the wider
point he was clumsily trying to make I
think it is
indisputable that the Palestinians have
been suffering repression now for many
decades it's indisputable we go back to
1948 that hundreds of thousands of them
were displaced from their homes and that
was the Catalyst for everything that's
followed and you can argue as some
journalists have been doing this week I
think very powerfully actually Jewish
journalists that I respect very highly
saying you can you can say that both
sides have just calls historically over
the land issues and everything else but
this attack on October the 7th was a a
completely different scale yeah of
attack and I don't think you should look
at anything else but that in terms of
what is Israel's response and the
question for me having said that and I
think you would agree with that is what
is proportionate here so I want to be
very clear about where I stand on this
as someone running for us president I'm
not running for president of the UN I
mean Secretary General of the UN
whatever it is I'm not running for
president of Israel I'm running for
president of the United States of
America and my prism and I think that
this is going to be the foundation of a
future that will lead to Greater peace
in the United States and I think around
the world is to be very candid that my
decisions will be made through one
filter what advances the interests of
the United States of America and I don't
believe that it advances the United
States of America for us to assume the
position of a shadow icj and
international court of justice deciding
what is or isn't proportionate from our
armchair position in Washington DC when
we have problems of our own and threats
of our own to deal with and so my view
is again Pierce this is part of the
broken foreign policy establishment in
both political parties once you've
crossed that Rubicon then yes you're
committed to take stances on each of
these questions let me ask you this it's
not my job to adjudicate this as the US
president there are the injustices in
this country to most of the American
people that's a massive departure that
would be a massive dep departure for any
American president to say has nothing to
do with us right I I would say that
Trump took us a step in that direction
but this is a very different direct this
is this is far further in that direction
Trump if he was sitting here now he
wouldn't be saying this about I can't
anticipate what he would say but I can
St from my view here even as it relates
to the UN I I think that there's an open
conversation to be had about whether
continued involvement in the UN serves
the US's or anybody else purpose so NATO
I think is is a different conversation
from the UN I do think that there's a
convers first a table Stakes
conversation with NATO when you have a
majority of its members still not
meeting it's minimum 2% absolutely G
that's why Donald Trump isy right about
that well I know but against what back
stop right so if an institution any
institution outlives its purpose it's
worth reflecting on the continued
existence of that institution many of
these multilateral institutions like
government agencies sometimes at home
these things should have been task
forces but an American president has to
have a moral compass too I do about
whatever's going on anywhere in the
world have a moral compass particularly
if they are allies that you are helping
to fund and right now as youe treaty
bound allies now there a treaty that
that means something okay my question is
this right now there are thousands of
children you're a father two young kids
I'm a father of four kids there are
thousands of young children getting
killed in Gaza innocent Palestinian kids
half the half of Gaza kids women being
blown to Pieces houses and whole areas
being complet completely decimated a
million garans have had to move from the
north to the South out of their homes
which they will not be able to return to
in most cases because they've been
destroyed and they're going to be
destroyed and I get that the purpose the
Israel stated Mission purpose is to get
rid of Hamas and I agree with them but
how they do that the whole world is
watching and the other parts of the
region including Saudi Arabia they're on
the verge of a new Accord with Israel
and now recoiling at what they see as a
dispropor
response so I disagree with some of that
characterization my question
long-winding question but my question is
on on a human level with the moral
compass required by an American
president do you not look at what's
happening now in Gaza and slightly
recoil at the scale of this and what it
may become in the next days weeks
potentially months do you not
think responsible American president
wouldn't say to prime minister Netanyahu
just hang on here so so if I if I may
pearon I appreciate you providing the
backdrop for that question and I'm not
giving you the answer no I know you're
not I'm asking you yeah and I I take it
as a as a question yeah as a difficult
question it's a difficult
answer on that standard we would have
been engaging with most of the African
continent for the better part of the
last half century we would be talking
much more about what's going on in the
last three years in azaran and Armenia
somehow interestingly something you
don't hear PE peep about in the nagoro
region we could go on and each of us has
different capacities I mean you and I
sure multiple things in common we're
both fathers we've both lived the full
Arc of what in this country at least we
call the American dream right you've
been
successful I have a separate hat that I
wear as a philanthropist I look to other
parts of the world including especially
the United States where I'm able to make
a difference not the US president yet
I've been you know as helpful as I can
from East Palestine Ohio to Maui to
chartering a flight that helping pay for
a chartered flight for 200 seats
for Americans to get out of Harm's Way
in Israel that's different from the
public policy had I wear I've been a
businessman that's developed medicines
to deliver medicines to patients who
need them some of them life- saving but
as US president which is the premise for
our discussion here as US president I
have a moral obligation it is to the
citizens of the United States of America
and this is there's a philosophy
underlying this I me you said you and
our fathers you caught my you if you're
going to catch my attention it worked it
caught me
Our obligation I think perhaps you would
agree with me it's the way I sense it I
my first obligation in the way I've
lived my life to this date is to my
family to those two sons those two boys
we're raising and then we go concentric
circles to my nation I'm a citizen of
this nation not some nebulous Global
citizen fighting climate change
nebulously somewhere else I'm a citizen
of this nation if I'm running to lead
this nation as commander and gief I do
have a moral obligation this is my moral
compass speaking my moral compass is to
the United States of America and once we
have dealt with wage stagnation and a
border crisis and the people who are
suffering in this country the people who
are suffering for threats vulnerable to
cyber attacks super EMP attacks nuclear
missile attacks from a Russia China
Alliance that poses a great threat to
the United States and our citizens today
once we've dealt with that then maybe we
can get to hunger in the Congo after
that but that's the order we need to go
in yeah but this sounds if you don't mom
me saying it sounds incredibly
isolationist it's not isolationist it's
like taking Trump Trump's world view
it's not isolationist
doubling down and making even more insul
it sounds to me like the kind of
presidency you want is one where you
only really care about direct impact on
American citizens which by the way I do
that's that much I'm guilty of that much
I will Adit I get it direct impact on
American Citi but I don't think the
number one superpower in the world can
just ignore a moral compass elsewhere in
the world particularly in countries
which are your allies so so I'm not I
mean I come from the United Kingdom for
example if we had if we had an a tack
like this would you have the same
philosophy to us I mean it's a treaty
about an ally right so I think treaties
mean something and this is where I think
but where is your moral line with what's
happening in Israel right now let's
let's work backwards here from an
outcome we both want to avoid World War
II right how did World War I the arch
duuk ferdinand's death escalate into a
massive war that killed Millions around
the world only to lay the groundwork for
then World War II which killed Millions
more their accidental trip wires that
people cross that then create escalation
that nobody imagined and yet in
retrospect becomes a configration I
think we lose that Clarity when we're
vague saying there's selectively certain
and admittedly you're cty have a problem
with no no no but you're picking certain
conflicts or certain areas of
humanitarian crisis while outright
ignoring others get so I say look at it
through the if I one one one quick
thought just to finish this because I
think you can you can then at least
understand the view even if you
disagree I'm not saying don't get
involved or not I'm saying the question
of whether or not we get involved is is
decided through one prism of whether it
advances the American interest and so
there may be certain cases in which we
do make the determination that that does
advance the American interest I'll give
you one right now Taiwan if China were
to invade Taiwan right now I think it is
the job of the US to affirmatively
defend why because we depend on Taiwan
for semiconductors that power our modern
way of life so you would if you were
president you'd send troops in to defend
Taiwan I would defend Taiwan and I'm not
going to Telegraph exactly which means
there are many means to do you hav't
said that before we've run a I've said
that before people don't listen but I've
said that before you changed your
position on that no I've actually been
crystal clear on this at every step of
the way now what I've also said where
you might be getting
that politics thing is interesting you
know I don't fault you for it because
that's that's what's in The Ether I've
said that very clearly we will defend
Taiwan at least until we get
semiconductor Independence in the United
States at which point we will resume our
current posture of strategic ambig
defend Taiwan militarily but not Israel
well I think that right now we depend on
those little semiconductors for our
modern way of life just purely finan
Israel also doesn't need it Israel but
Israel provides a lot of stuff to
America well here's my point each and
this is the whole point Pier say it's
not some top down cookie cutter
analogizing I analyze each situation
indep Co principle Israel is able to
defend itself right now and I think
Israel will be better able to defend
itself if we don't muddy the watersan
has no chance defending and it matters
to the US your red line you said to me
was American interest it was if American
citizens got attacked we will hit you
back 10 times harder okay but American
citizens were ATT so that's what makes
this conflict difficult is Israel able
to take care of that job if American
targets are hit as American targets
right let's say they know they're
hitting us on an American base that's a
direct hit on the United States if
Americans get killed in Israel well if
Americans kidnapped and taken hostage by
Hamas we need to well right now you
don't see any I prioritize getting those
American hostages out that is a top
priority I it is a top priority for me
American Min now right now let's just
let's be Tethered to the facts as they
exist they've been releasing hostages
two at a time there's reports yesterday
of Hamas willing to do a deal for
American hostages to apparently a
collapsed which is why the Israelis have
started the ground war so if I'm so if
I'm commander-in-chief my top focus and
there's a lot of levers here but you
prioritize what matters getting American
hostages home top priority so you would
send sons and daughters so just to
clarify you would send American troops
in to get the hostages I would not take
option off the table in a limited way to
protect Americans right you protect
Americans America First includes all
Americans you did say earlier that you
would not want to send any American
Military into their situation I don't
want US military involvement in somebody
else's War you just said you send troops
in to get the hostages American hostages
only the American hostages Special
Forces targeted but Pi you're paying
attention to the negotiations I trust
there are very clear delineations that
Hamas has drawn right now for releasing
civilian hostages of other nations just
to clar
clarifi for this I mean you're not
seriously suggesting that you would send
in American troops down to get hostages
forces or otherwise negotiators but
literally only get American hostages
rather than say Israeli hostages the the
only condition under which we will have
shown up there was because they hold
American hostages right but but if we're
there we're going to do the best deal we
can to to to advance American interest
which includes releasing isra I would
say there inconsistency to what you've
now been saying about this because you
started by saying we should have no
military involvement in this whatsoever
what I have said piers at every step
I'll bring you back the North Star what
advances the American interest that will
be my prism that's different in
different situations but the question is
what advances the American interest and
to me the America First agenda includes
all Americans I did my part as I said I
I personally paid for a charter flight
with 200 seats to get people out of
Harm's Way I've told you at the bases in
Syria and Iraq if I'm commander-in-chief
I want to bring those Sons and Daughters
home and yes it would be a top priority
if you're commander-in-chief you're
making decisions holistically a top
priority to bring our host our American
hostages being held by Hamas yes and it
sounds to me by your criteria that
you've set out today in this interview
that by that criteria as American
president you would send American troops
in the only reason I criticize that
question Pierce is that there are many
other ways short of that that we can get
those hostages home now it is literally
happening as we speak and or having this
conversation so that is a strawman
relative to the status quo of deal
discussion with hostages actually being
released and brought home and if you're
US president you're not making each
decision in isolation what your moral
you set certain priorities and a top
priority for me is American hostages
what but what is your moral compass
though if you were to
witness Israel for example if this
escalates and Israel which is believed
to be a nuclear power they don't admit
it but they beli to have nule Israel is
almost certainly nuclear power if they
were to suddenly use a nuclear weapon
would that cross a red line for you so
my view is this what advances the
American interest I don't mean to sound
like a broken record those circum like a
broken record well the but but but I
wanted to offer Clarity at a moment
where I risked maybe sounding ambiguous
to you the real answer is each of those
situations has to be looked at through
the prism of what caus my overarching
question was was is there a limit to
what you would accept Israel doing as
president of the United States is there
a full accordance with international law
and the laws of war do you think at the
moment they are acting in accordance
with international law and the Geneva
Convention because many think they're I
I believe there is no evidence to
suggest that they're outside of that in
the context of the laws of just
engagement in the context of what Hamas
did I mean I absolutely think they have
a right to defend themselves of what
happened I think they're right to try
and get rid of Hamas I've got to say
when I am looking at my social media
feed at the moment and I'm seeing a
constant bombardment quite literally of
these terrible scenes out of Gaza with
screaming kids and women who've been
slain and so on and so on and whole are
is just completely
leveled I'm looking at this and getting
increasingly concerned about the
proportionality of what is happening and
also in the understanding that clearly
it's going to get a lot worse and if I'm
the American President Joe Biden has
already said he's very concerned about
this
right it seems to me what you're trying
to say correct me if I'm wrong but that
Israel can do what it wants that after
that attack there is no limit as far as
you're concern sitting in the white
house there is no limit and a lot of
people will hear that particular let me
let me just challeng one Prem finish
question a lot of people will hear this
particularly Americans American Arabs
will hear this and they'll think what
there's no limit the American president
has no moral line that Israel can cross
in their desire to get rid of Hamas I
think there's one troubling premise
baked in there which is that the US is
the only nation that can have a moral
compass I mean you're presuming that is
what's baked into that question let's
every country should have but what
what's I my country honestly I didn't
let my country abstaining on the issue
of a ceasefire have a view I was think
abstention I I also say have a view you
and I share that in common abion is lame
a lame it's a particularly lame respon
cowardly it's exception is is a lame
response have a view and defend it if
you're going to be at the table of a
body like the UN if it should exist in
the first place but what's baked into
the premise of your question is that
Israel has no moral compass and
therefore it's the US's job to have one
saying that well but but it is it's
baked in the premise of your question
that Israel is doing something the US
has a moral compass deci as you know
there are a lot of people yeah around
the world Millions hundreds of millions
right especially in the Muslim world but
not just the Muslim and why are we
picking on this humanitarian C
catastrophe or alleged humanarian
catastrophe but not countless others in
other parts of the world over the course
of the last 20 years I think there are
leads to a slippery
slope for the US to actually manage and
so we come back to what are the
relations between nations the job of
each nation is to look after its
National self- is it fair that Israel is
able to turn on for example power and
water and turn it off for the whole of
it wasn't fair that Hamas came from Gaza
into Israel on hang gliders to kill
innocent civilians the
UN boss clumsily put it this is not a
new conflict this has been going is it
fair that the Arab people the
descendants of Ishmael have 20 some odd
countries yet none of them will take on
the Palestinians even as they nominally
stand for them against
the so I think these are questions that
we should Elevate in our capacity as
Citizens and as leaders diplomatically
and I think this may hearing you
appears this may be actually we might
have a lot more common ground than the
last 10 minutes might suggest there's a
role for diplomacy I mean I'm not as
certain in my view as you seem to be
well there's there's a role for
diplomacy here so is the role for the US
to engage
diplomatically yes around the world I
think the US's accomplishment one of the
US accomplishments under the Trump
Administration that I respect was the
Abraham Accords that was a diplomatic
achievement not a military achievement
and I think we should take those
diplomatic achievements to the next
level and so if I'm to level set our
conversation
we might have risked talking past each
other a little bit it's not that I want
to be an ideologue and just say that
we're going to be completely callous and
have no view on it we have a view but
what I'm going to do about it is going
to be determined by the American
self-interest one thing you've said
today a diplomatic engagement and even
that diplomatic engagement would be
through the American Self having that
conversation something that good leaders
can do okay you talk about diplomacy was
it diplomatic of you I think you
repeated it again in your speech today
to say that if if it was left to you uh
you know you'd see Israel putting up the
heads of the top 100 not that if it's
left to me if it's left to Israel and
that's what they decide to do I'm
perfectly okay with that your idea yeah
was that they put the heads on Stakes of
the hund top Hamas leaders that's not
diplomacy is it and that's going to be
literally a pouring a bucket of fuel
onto a raging fire I I actually think
that that might be far better Pierce as
an alternative really to a prolonged
ground Invasion with Gaza involving a
bunch of civilians versus taking the top
100 leaders of a terrorist organization
that are carrying out for of genocide
isn't that the kind of medieval
barbarism which they perpetrated on the
people of Israel on October the 7th
which I think there's one crucial
difference the Civilized World should
seek to be above appears there's there's
a real difference there a fundamental
difference one is an armed militia doing
it against civilians versus is going
after the perpetrators and I
specifically said the top hundred
leaders of Hamas and this is a fun
conversation it's interesting to me
because I've actually just taken
objections the other way saying that
that's far too Limited in scope right
just to say the top 100 leaders of Hamas
well why wouldn't we expand the scope of
who we hold responsible so yes I do
think that's diplom Obama never showed
images of a dead AMA Bin Laden he didn't
feel that would be the right thing to do
he felt that would be too inflammatory
is my understanding well I'll say two
things in response to that Barack Obama
is not my Arbiter of what counts as good
diplomacy or not and second is each
situation is different I mean each
situation is different about asking what
is in the American self-interest so I'm
not saying on the Israel point I was
very clear in my speech when I brought
this up that is I said it about three
times that is Israel's decision to
make not ours and I think that that of
provides a level of yes moral clarity
about who the leader of a Nation owes an
obligation to David benan had a vision
for Israel self-sufficiency makes its
own decisions for its own security
George Washington in his farewell
address in the United States of America
had a vision for this nation the lead
founding father of our nation that we
look to the interests of our citizens
without foreign entanglements and I
think if we're honest about that I
actually think that that opens up
greater possibility for peace everywhere
because both our allies and our
adversaries can actually trust what we
say red lines will actually be red lines
because if they're crossed it means it
really violates the national
self-interest one of the other I look at
it one of the other candidates for
president Ronda Sanz has said that the
students who've been protesting across
American campuses um very Pro
Palestinian a lot of Jewish students
feeling very threatened by it some of
these students actually beaming pramas
imagery to the buildings at George
Washington University and so on that
they should be taken out uh if they have
visas they should be revoked and so on
you've said you don't believe in that
because of Free Speech but again is
there no limit to that Free Speech if
people are actively supporting and
promoting a terror organization like
Hass that's isn't that hate speech not
free speech well to be clear I am a
Ardent defender of the First Amendment
so and I agree with it so the First
Amendment does not protect against
incite actual incitement to violence to
say hey go kill that guy right there do
it now shoot him that's not protecting
about saying ham is so in the US the
Juris Prudence on this I mean the US is
very clear anything that is an
expression of an opinion is protected so
if you're expressing an opinion however
heinous that opinion is protected by the
First Amendment all opinions are
protected now my view is some of those
are heinous opinions we're the country
the United States of America who said
the Nazis could March in skoki Illinois
many people around the world would
disagree with that but that's what makes
America itself I disagree vehemently
with those Nazis but I will defend to
the death this country in this country
the right of anybody to express their
opinion you'll defend to a death the
right of people to be Nazis in America I
write the right of people to express an
opinion being a Nazi can involve more
than that right if you're taking action
based on that no heck no but if you want
to but if you're promoting and
supporting a Nazi ideology why would you
want to accept that in America I don't
want to accept that the way we defeat it
why would you tolerate it tolerate it we
don't tolerate it through free more
speech you defeat it in the marketplace
of ideas and we're not tolerating it
because think about what you're doing to
somebody who has that nasty opinion and
then tell them that they have to keep it
to themselves you tell people they can't
speak they scream would you allow people
if you tell people they can't scream
that's when they take physical action so
I don't want to see that would you be
happy to see Pro Nazi no I'm not happy
of course I'm not happy president United
States you would allow it to happen Nazi
marches I I'll tell you something deeper
appears this is how it works in the
United States
it's not even my power to decide whether
to allow it to happen the Constitution
and the Supreme Court has already long
held that the expression of heinous
opinions is part of the American
constitutional life to say that the
government no government actor should
ever decide which opinions can and
cannot be expressed period that's what
the first amendment is all about once we
lose that once the government can decide
which ideas can and cannot be expressed
that's the ball game and and I've been
the major defender of this from a
right-wing perspective for years right
saying that conservatives should be
allowed to express skepticism of Co
vaccines or the origin of the co
pandemic or questions relating to race
or questions relating to asking you have
your vaccines again if you had your your
time as a side not that's true yeah why
I'm a young healthy man and I think that
we have risks of myocarditis that are
revealed now that weren't revealed then
the only reason I took it was a matter
of convenience we could travel you do
accept our presume that many millions of
people have their lives saved by the
vaccines I think by vaccines other than
Co 19 sure I think the co 19 vaccines I
think that there's a deeper debate to be
had about the cost you they saved
millions of lives well I think I think
the costs exceeding the benefits are
really a case by human life the question
is how many human lives were lost also
as a consequence of myocarditis or other
risks that are yet untested absolutely
tiny number so this is this is an area
that strikes near and dear I've studied
the myard thing extremely thoroughly
including in young men what the cost
benefit anal well because actually I've
got three sons in their 20s and at least
one of them thought he may have had my
card so I studied personal to you so I I
developed five medicines which are FDA
approved today the ultimate hypocrisy at
the heart of our regulatory regime
here's his on one hand and I'm an
absolutist in both directions here on
one hand this FDA in the US that says
you can't even try a medicine or a
vaccine unless it's been through 10
years of testing you don't have the
right to try it I reject that I'm a
right to try absolutist I think you
should be able to make an informed
decision for yourself of whether you
want to take take that risk or not but
part of being a right to try absolutist
is I'm a right not to try absolutist too
just because the FDA has pushed it
through nobody should be mandated to
take but you're not suggesting just to
be clear you're not suggesting that more
people died of
myocarditis as a result of taking
vaccines than the number of people whose
lives were I'm not making an empirical
claim I'm making a normative claim that
everybody should be able to decide for
themselves there was a tiny number of
people who died from myocarditis and
every vaccine has people who have
reactions I'm not I'm not diminishing I
think they were
deer I'm not was a problem nor am I
saying that with hindsight clearly
younger people were not as affected by
CO as older people we now know that as a
fact so My Philosophy as a policy maker
is medical Choice absolute in both
directions medical choice to try what
hasn't been approved you should have the
right to make that informed decision and
just because it has been approved under
no condition should it be mandated
that's that's the policymaking matter
let me read you a quote from Nikki Haley
one of your other Rivals to be president
she says you want to go and defund
Israel you you want to give Taiwan to
China you want to go and give Ukraine to
Russia under your watch you will make
America less safe now we've discussed
Israel you've clarified your position on
Taiwan and I think it's significant that
you now said you would send in American
troops to defend Taiwan should China try
and attack it I said we would militarily
defend you'd send troops in milit it
depends on whether ground troops are
actually what matter or not you could
talk about destroyers you could talk
about ssgn would send American Military
in to defend we would militarily defend
Taiwan yes at least until we've achieved
semiconductor Independence that wasn't
and I'm the only candidate who said it
but it wasn't what you used to say
Pierce that's false I have said yeah it
is false you can check this for yourself
I have always said the part that these
people are picking at is the fact that I
said at least until Taiwan gain
semiconductor Independence so you look
at my early statements on this all way
back to the Nixon Library so here's
where I'm curious again at least until
semiconductor Independence is the part
that these people trip up on all right
so here's where I'm curious again so if
Taiwan gets attacked and invaded yes by
an authoritarian regime like China you
wouldn't hesitate to have a American
Military defendant and you know why well
no you've explained why yeah because we
depend on them for our modern way of
life that is business okay so well not
business it's our modern way of life
these lights wouldn't work right now and
our phones would this brings me neatly
to Ukraine yes which was invaded and
attacked it's a it's a sovereign
Democratic country it was attacked
Democratic with an asterisk no no democ
asterisk well it had a massive majority
voted for democracy well much of the
regions that occupied haven't been
represented in Ukrainian in Ukraine's
Parliament for N9 years right so table
Stakes discussion there but is okay you
can call it as democ I'll say democracy
but it was attacked and invaded by
Russia uh and you originally when you
first tweeted about it you were quite
censorious about what Russia had done
and pro Ukraine your rhetoric I Pro
Ukraine but I but I but I found it
offensive I mean I've said this every
step Putin is a craven dictator okay
Putin is absolutely a craven dictator
is he a war criminal I don't know I
don't have enough information to suggest
he a war criminal the icj makes that
judgment again the US the US president
you don't think what he's done in
Ukraine constitutes a war crime based on
what we've seen a lot of it looks likely
to meet the icj's test but I don't think
the US president it makes it meets any
test well I think that a lot of people
have committed war crimes then on that
basis right so you can't just
selectively single him out well
illegally invading a sovereign country
is a crime is for us to get on the same
page is Putin an evil dictator yes he is
just because Putin is bad does that mean
Ukraine is good no it does not okay this
is a country that has banned 11
opposition parties this is a country
that has Consolidated all of its media
into one state TV media arm this is a
country that celebrated a Nazi in its
own ranks in front of the Canadian
Parliament zalinsky did this is a
country that's effectively threatening
the us not to hold its elections unless
the US Forks Over more money and also
against the backdrop peers it's worth
wondering why that initial incursion to
keev went nowhere but lansen donet were
easily captured without counter
resistance why these are Russian
speaking region many residents there
don't even view themselves as part of
Ukraine they view themselves as part of
Russia and for the better part of the
last decade almost 10 years they haven't
even been represented in the Ukrainian
Parliament there large we have to
measure that against the fact LGE ways
of United States English speaking should
we should we have it back what's that
large parts of America are English
speaking should we have have that back
well all of criteria all of them have
been represented in the revenge for
George third's incompetence well hang on
you're all speaking English every one of
them get so actually we're having it all
back I think you're you're purpos you
may not be purply avoiding the I might
be king of United States of America it's
a dream of many Englishmen perhaps but
that's okay it's not going to happen no
I don't get your point because the whole
point is they weren't represented in
Ukraine's government okay and the United
States national identity is different
than the cultural identity of the people
in the ideologically what's the
difference between racing racing
American Military to defend Taiwan but
but in your case wanting to stop funding
American Military Support for Ukraine
right at the moment many would say it's
never been more important because my
basis for preventing China from invading
Taiwan right now was not that Taiwan is
a democracy my basis for doing money is
that there's American self-interested
issue our modern way about all the food
stuffs that come out of Ukraine our food
self we could be self-sufficient in this
country the food stuffs that come from
Ukraine to the United States is not
going to affect our modern way of life I
mean that's the hard answer so for you
secure Financial calculation it's not
just Financial self-interest it's it's
not a moral calculation of whether the
US selfed selfish it's American Centric
and I think it was actually selfish for
the leaders of the United States to
indulge their moral vanities while
leaving Americans holding the bag here
at home and here's the other thing
Pierce we're not having this
conversation in a vacuum look at this
how how well has this gone forking over
nearly $200 billion direct and in kind I
think it's gone incredibly I tell you I
think it's gone I think it's gone let me
exp disastrous let me explain why
everybody assumed that Putin would run
over ke take control that was a wrong
assumption Pi out rest because because
there was a Ukrainian counter Insurgency
there because ukrainians fought for
their Democratic rights and why didn't
they fight in the dawn freedom and I
remember a time when America used to
celebrate you're missing one this you're
missing one super important detail here
you actually made your own made the
point that I would like to make which is
the reason why Russia has succeeded in
the parts of the dbas they're occupying
is that the people there have more of an
affinity for Russia than they do to
Ukraine so you can't say democracy
sometimes but
these people don't want to be part of
Ukraine it isn't actually true because
most of the of them the polls show that
the people in those regions still want
to be part of Ukraine many of them don't
and that's why there was no
counterinsurgency some don't I was told
it was like 10 to 15 they haven't been
represented in Lanson yet small
percentage they have not even been
represented in the Ukrainian Parliament
would you really if you won the
presidency in 2024 I would do a deal
that ends this What's your deal I mean
you and Donald Trump talking about we
going sort it I'll give you detail in my
case I'll give you detail you give you
would give Putin what he's taken I won't
give I won't give give him anything
there's a deal what would you give him I
wouldn't give him anything I would give
him a deal what's the deal he's going to
take that well here's the deal he has to
exit his military alliance with Xi
Jinping end the Russia China military
Alliance that's the top threat that the
US what do with Ukraine and in return
what we get is a hard commitment that
NATO will not admit Ukraine to Nato in
truth that's just keeping what about the
land you well this is the most important
part is the NATO hard this is what
matters most to Putin there's other
parts of this deal I can talk about on
both sides the most important element of
each and then I can go to the second
most
the most important element is Russia
exit its military alliance with China we
make a hard commitment that NATO not
admit Ukraine to Nato which by the way
peers that violates we've systematically
violated a commitment we made back in
1990 James Baker the US Secretary of
State made a commitment to G tell me on
this deal and then and then here we
would freeze the current lines of
control what freeze the current lines of
control you give Putin
everything I would freeze the current
lines of control what you mean what does
that mean these are Russians speaking
regions that are occupied today you
would literally give Putin what he's
stolen you would give a guy I'm not
giving anything I'm giving him a deal
what did you describe him as to me it's
conditioned what did you call Putin he's
an evil dictator you give an evor so are
countless others land he's stolen by
killing people you would give him the
land Pierce I'm not going to give him
anything I'm giving him a deal you've
just said you give him the whole I'm not
going to give him that's your word not
mine I give him a deal what I would do
is no we would require Russia to exit
its military alliance with China what
threatens the United States of America
you CH milary allian you're president of
the United States and you say all right
uh Vladimir I know you invaded illegally
a sovereign Democratic country and they
fought for it's not a democratic country
Ukraine is not a democratic country
don't agree with you I mean look at what
they're doing to the Ukrainian Orthodox
church right now let meish this is it's
just a myth but we're having a
mythological conversation Ukraine is not
a democratic country people of Ukraine
voted for democracy a massive majority
except for the ones that didn't vote
that happen to be in the regions
occupied by Russia but you would give
this area they've stolen back to the
Russians right right so you're tell
you're telling condition you're telling
I would not do anything other than we
get what we want you're telling every
evil dictator in the world you can go
and invade any country you like take
whatever land you can in a Bloody War
for as long as you here what I find fasc
eventually I'll just give it to how much
how many hours of your show or minutes
or seconds have you dedicated to what
azerbijan has done to Armenia and nagoro
kabak on the different region on the
other side of Caspian zero is probably
the answer just like every other me
major member of the media why because
Ukraine has been as successful in
selling this Pi Piper myth in the United
States as aeran has yet what aeran just
did in nagoro kabak over the same region
dating back to even September of this
year pin drop silence so if you're going
to apply that standard you would be
applying it far more broadly but
applying your standard as president of
the United States my my standard is stay
out of them all because if you're in
Ukraine for that reason the United
States would be in 10 other conflicts
right now and so you're selectively
applying it if I may say Pierce not even
to the best example you could make
Ukraine is not a paragon of ch's quote
about crocodiles and appeases right well
that's applied selectively analogizing
some element of history as opposed to
analyzing what the individual situation
is and so where is aeran Armenia why is
that not part of the conversation just
because the media has decided that that
isn't what we're going to pay attention
to because it's not what the cool kids
are talking about likely because it's
Christians at stake let's be honest
about that so this is a country in
Ukraine that's gone after the Ukrainian
Orthodox Church this is a country that
has banned 11 opposition parties this is
a country where the regions of Russia
that have been occupied several of those
provinces lansen donet in particular not
even represented in the Ukrainian
Parliament so the idea that this is some
Battle of good versus evil is a farce
and even if you're going to pick good
versus evil there's a lot other better
examples to pick and I'm principled to
say that we should not be making those
moral judgments for other people when my
moral obligation is to the people the
unit States of America but you have just
made a moral judgment you've actually
said to an evil dictator you can come
and grab that land and keep it that
presumes that it was our job Jud it
presumes that it was our job to be able
to say yes or no in the first place that
is not the job of the United States of
America the job of the United States of
America is to be strong and look after
its own citizen we have a different view
US it used to be maybe from an out you
know maybe from looking from old
fash call me old fashioned but I
remember in World War II when the
Americans came in to help Britain finish
off when Pearl Harbor was hit yes I mean
it's the hard answer is better late than
never would be my response to that well
America
when America was attacked itself then
America did come into the war and did
help Britain win it that's correct when
America was hit that happened thank God
they did and I I'm grateful that America
and Europe should be grateful that we
did and now NATO can spend maybe 2% of
its GDP on military spending which it's
still failing to do so much for
gratitude so on that point I agree with
you and I agree with Donald Trump and he
he did the right thing when he said NATO
was obsolete he meant the way the
finances are not being paid by a lot of
the member countries they're just not a
majority of them are and they should be
um let's turn to conspiracy theories
people think you're a conspiracy
theorist H are you no I'm a conspiracy
realist I believe in actually some of
the most mundane so-called conspiracies
have been obvious realities hiding in
plain sight think people said it was a
conspiracy theory by the way when I said
that the like many others the coid
pandemic originated in a lab in Wuhan
back when we're supposed to buy this wet
Market did and most likely that it did
so I think history has taught us that
many of things that we reject do you
believe the I'm Guided by fact do you
believe the Sandy Hook massacre was a
hoax no do you think the the parents of
those kids who died were actors no okay
so why did you appear on Alex Jones's
show those are two very different
questions because he two fundamentally
different questions well they're not
because in fact this is a guy who's
propagated I invited him on my podcast
and in that particular instance I gave
him an opportunity to say what people
should listen to this actually what
respects everybody what did he say he
said he was wrong so what he said he
came on we sat in a conversation just
like this one he said he was wrong and
he regretted it
and so I think that this culture of
creating why would you invite someone
like that onto your podcast who give me
some examples of people you've have you
ever isn't it called Truth have you ever
T what's your podcast truth truth and to
truth runs through free speech and open
debate so you have the worst liar in
America a man who call see I don't
believe in creating obstacles to let me
finish my character assessment of Alex
Jones right I didn't make a character
assessment I'm about to make one of him
right because as you know he was found
guilty in October 2022 of defaming the
families of aandy Hook victims after
years monetizing the lie that it was a
hoax and the families of the Dead were
actors he's been ordered to pay a
collective 1.5 billion dollars to the
people who he so sickeningly defamed and
there's you a guy who wants to be
president of the United States inviting
this guy saying that was dead wrong it
was dead wrong now my view though pieres
and the whole premise of the podcast all
the people I've talked to Chris Christie
said when he heard you did that he said
I could care less for what Chris
Christie has
on own well I think it's disqualifying
to anybody who believes that we have to
preordain who we do and don't talk to
you give platforms to just blatant
conspiracy theorists to come on and talk
about the truth I think that part of the
reason is what's a conspiracy theory
yesterday is a truth tomorrow you
challeng him about Sandy Hook I did and
I told you what he said actually for as
far as I know the first time I've heard
it said I think it was useful he said it
was wrong he regretted it he made a
mistake human beings have made mistakes
not the first time he said he said it to
me well good so what you platformed him
yeah well interesting Pierce IAT why
would you do that because I spent the
entire interviewing interview going
after him about his Wicked lies also had
a mother one of the victims on because I
was on air at CN open debate is good I
like you for re I like you for that
reason but I think the American way is
not to decide there's certain parayas
and people we don't talk to far left far
right I mean look I went on The Young
Turks podcast something the Republican
presidential candidate doesn't do either
I practice what I preach when a
protester shows up up to my I I was in
Iowa crazy protester just barges in in
the back of the event security is taking
her out I said bring her back we'll give
her the microphone that's just how I
roll I believe it's the founding Spirit
of the United States of America that all
ideas get expressed and the way we
defeat bad ideas is through free speech
and open debate and and so unlike others
peers I practice I you got again you've
got to have some limits I don't I
disagree with that well then with with
respect to the expression of opinions
violence is a limit right I mean I don't
stand for violence of any form Direct
lies did inspire people to commit acts
of violence against these families
people turned up and threatened them as
an act of violence he literally of a
vience withes the in the the expression
of a heinous opinion is different than
not and it was taken to the court system
we have I mean the court systems have
handled this that's different from
saying that somebody should not be
talked to by a fellow American I just
don't think that's the American way let
me talk to you about guns generally
because there was another horrible mass
shooting yeah in America in the last few
days 18 people killed um I saw your
Tweet response and it was a very
conventional Republican response to mass
shootings of which there are now so many
you can almost hardly get over the one
before before another one and it was all
about mental health and this and this
and the one thing you didn't it's really
important to it's not like a mental
health I mean this is a real fundamental
Topic in many other countries have
mental health problems just at the same
level that America does the difference
about America almost exclusively of
anywhere in the world is that America
has 400 million plus firearms in
circulation so when people are mentally
unstable or sick they have easy access
to guns and you didn't mention the word
gun in your in your statement I was
curious why not do you not think guns
play a part in gun massacres well
obviously guns definitionally for your
you know question somewhat tological
there guns play a role in guns massacres
they don't play a role in massacres of
other kinds do you think guns kill
people I think people kill people using
guns and using other instruments to do
it have you give you my policy
perspective you're interested in let me
ask have you someone shoot someone we
let you indulge with what the let clever
framing you have let me get the question
right have youever known the clever
known a human being shoot somebody dead
without a
gun I I I know whatever the setup is
I'll give you whatever the I lost track
of setup but what whatever the premises
that's the question guns have been
people have pulled the trigger of guns
have killed people I I think let's just
get that on the table yeah sure
tological but you think that's useful
policy question I'm curious look as as a
citizen who has a home in America I can
go and get a semi-automatic rifle very
easily tomorrow yeah and I'm not even an
American citizen I just have to apply
for a hunting license give my American
address and I and I'll get access to any
Firearms I want I can I can Ki myself up
like Rambo right Legally Legally what I
can't do in America is buy a Kinder
surprise chocolate egg they're banned on
safety grounds well I think that makes
no sense you're a very bright man I'm a
medical food choice can you explain to
me why it's deemed more dangerous that I
should have a chocolate egg with a
little toy inside that might choke
people compared to an AR15
semi-automatic rifle that could
slaughter a lot of people in a very
short period of time so I am a pro-
freedom person and so I'm not going to
sit here and defend some other foolish
restriction that the United States has
on a million things that I'm generally
against but I can speak to the Second
Amendment the Second Amendment is not
about a technocratic judgment of about
maximizing or minimizing the number of
people who were killed the second
amendment is about something else
altogether it's analogous to the
discussion we just had about Free Speech
it's a different value judgment are
there risks to allowing Free Speech yes
there are but we bear those risks
because that's who we are that we trade
that risk off to say that's how we
preserve Freedom when it comes to the
First Amendment the second amendment
makes a similar value
judgment the purpose of the Second
Amendment actually wasn't to allow
people to have the freedom to hunt
that's not what it's about
it was about repelling and keeping a
foreign in that case started British
Monarchy at Bay it's like mutually
assured destruction in the Cold War both
sides have nuclear weapons well that's
how you assure a stable peace it's a
mutually assured destruction
relationship between the citizens and
their government between the governed
and their government right that's what
this is about and so why is the United
States of America still for all of our
imperfections 250 years into this ball
game still place that when you open the
borders as sadly one Administration has
people don't go running out but they
come running in why is it the country
that still gives hope to the Free World
one of the reasons why is the Bill of
Rights and the Second Amendment is the
one amendment that gives teeth to all of
the other amendments in that Bill of
Rights so that's a value judgment we
make the second amendment was not
written with the question of what
minimizes the number of deaths those are
other policies it was you could arm
yourself as part of a well regulated
militia and then over time actually
until the 880s
uh in America it was considered by the
Supreme Court to mean just that and then
as the NRA got more political and became
less apolitical and some hardcore
Republicans got onto the board of the
NRA they then put pressure on the
Supreme Court which they eventually were
successful in doing in reframing the
interpretation of a second amendment to
mean an individual right to bear arms
and what has happened I think the
history is a lot more complicated but
what has happened and it may be a
complete coincidence but what has
happened since that reframing of that
interpretation is that the number of
mass shootings in America has begun to
Skyrocket and they didn't used to happen
in anything like these numbers I think I
think we can debate my question you're a
smart guy right there were 400 million
plus guns in circulation in America it's
not for me to tell Americans how to lead
their lives it's not for me to tell you
what laws you should have you and your
president this is a major issue you're
going to have to confront I can
guarantee you that every month every six
weeks there will be a mass shooting of
some sign significance that will command
your response and every month a million
new guns will be sold in America adding
to the total that are available and
you're going to get as the population
increases more mentally ill people too
to me it's just a NeverEnding worsening
cocktail so my question really is what
do you do about if if no part of a
solution involves guns how do you ever
expect it to stop so I think that in the
data that you cited a lot of confounding
variables one of which is the rise of
Mental Health crisis in this country you
could look at data points over certain
periods where before you really saw rise
in violence you could see per capita gun
ownership being about flat over the same
period that you did see violence and
killings rise one of the biggest
explanations is the shuddering of
psychiatric hospitals in this country
you had to draw the lines of correlation
there are many ways to draw lines
through a scatter plot over the same
period that you saw the shuttering of
psychiatric institutions you saw almost
a direct inverse correlation in the
other direction in the rise of violent
crime in this country and so yes I do
think that is a major issue that we need
to address among other things by
bringing back those mental health
institutions allowing people to
communities to be able to under certain
conditions involuntarily commit somebody
who is psychiatrically ill and poses a
demonstrable danger this guy that just
did the L shooting that's exactly what
happened he was admitted to a a clinic
he should have remained committed said
he was hearing voices he actually said
I'm going to do a mass shooting he
should have remained committed and he
was allowed to go home where he had Le
there's but that the mistake in that
case I think in every case you have to
look at the circumstances yeah and so if
you're looking at Trends in every case
is different someone who loves America
and loves Americans I just see this as
such an extraordinarily bizarre thought
line that when when for example Osama
Bin Laden attacked America on 911 and
killed three around 3,000 people in the
World Trade Center everything changed
right there was an absolute visceral
determination by American to not let
that happen again and we made made we
made some bad mistakes in the aftermath
of that the Patriot Act and everything
else on down but I flew here for example
from New York to see you here in Vegas
and the amount of regulations that are
now involved in flying it changed
irrevocably after 911 and I would say
good right I feel safe and not just for
the purpose of convenience though per
for safety but it's for the purpose of
no no no but I'm going the other
direction I think those were mistakes we
made the surveillance don't you think
would you allow people to get on on on
planes with guns I mean the the idea
that the TS is doing anything but I mean
these checks they're garbage doesn't
make a difference would you make it
doesn't make an iota of a difference
it's show it's for show are you saying
you wouldn't restrict people from taking
firearms on on planes I mean I'm just
talking about a PIV a hard fact here
Pierce no people should know this people
should know this literally people are
allowed to right now allowed it happens
already right now private Aviation
literally literally of the thousands of
private flights that are happening every
day it's a farce we create in the
airports it's a show it's Village
standards on private planes are a
different issue but on commercial
commercial passenger flights at the
moment it's illegal for people to take
firearms on board a plane would you let
them do it I don't think the people
should be taking the infringement of
their second amendment rights so Pierce
is it the the surveillance state is the
real problem after 911 I get it okay
what's the answer to my question I think
the people should be able to check it in
in the cabin that's the answer really
check it in yeah you can't access it
what's the risk you would allow
Americans to just take or actually
anybody check it in in the I could go
get my gun and just take it on board not
in the passenger section of the cabin in
the check section of the cabin in the
hold yeah like they can't access it
while they're on actually in the cabin
cabin checkin not in the cabin you know
carry on your checkin back but this is
getting very pedestrian very quickly it
is and I think the question there's a
deeper philosophical question at I'm
actually philosophical question how you
stop all the mass shootings well first
question is who's committing the mass
shootings people who were severely
psychiatrically ill there a stat
something 18 out of 20 of the people
have committed the last number of Mass
Main young grown up in fatherless hous
young men right who grew up in unstable
family envir disenfranchised from
society the underly is they also almost
invariably able to acquire very high
powered in my estimation I know some got
so go after the Cure don't go after the
symptomatic After People The Cure get to
the root cause and you started talking
about it you're right you that tells me
you understand this no no I do
understand it and we have get to that
root cause disputing any of the root
causes you're putting forward but like
so get and let's so let's have the
courage to address those root causes
because anything else
a diversion it's going to show up
somewhere else I the symp as I said to
Donald Trump I would love a republican
politician because in Britain we have
very few guns and when we've had gun
outrages nobody's taken a political view
right or left it just didn't do it like
we had we had 16 well Britain's a very
different country and as somebody who we
don't have the guns I agree you say but
you this this is I'm enjoying this
discussion pierus you say you love the
United States of America I'm glad to
hear that I just want to make sure you
really know no no no I think it's Jones
tried that
he failed Barack Obama saved me for the
nation not my St true story what is that
Alex Jones got a petition up to have me
deported okay after My Views after Sandy
Hook well I believe in free speech and
open Obama was President was a White
House petition it reached the number
that required a response from the
president I was live on air when I was
told Barack Obama has saved you for the
American people I'm not entirely sure
the American people were massively
grateful at the time but I was grateful
to the president is that why you like
him I liked his you know what he said
and you'll love this he said he was
support
star of diplomacy my rights to the First
Amendment so if only he applied that
standard even-handedly when he
weaponized the IRS to go after
conservatives then I might even give an
iota of credit but back back to the
question of Your Love Of America yeah I
mean this in a you know we're having a
I'm not even going to cave out what I
say you've been pretty free with me I'll
be free with you please do keep my nose
out of it no no no no no no which I
totally understand no no no no no no no
that's that's a that's a cheap comment
I just make sure you know what you say
you love M right because I think that
there's parts of the United States of
America like the essence of who we are
not some Fringe feature the soul of the
United States of America that I think
make you a little uncomfortable I think
that's the truth I mean the idea that
anybody gets to express their opinion no
matter how heinous that opinion the idea
that you get to own a firearm for the
express purpose of holding the
government at Bay I think those ideas
make you uncomfortable I think those
ideas make a lot of people uncomfortable
I think those ideas make a lot of people
uncomfortable and this is something that
I have to then admit as an American and
I admit it and I embrace it like a badge
of honor the American ideals the
American Revolutionary ideals they're
not moderate ideals they are radical
ideals you know they're extreme ideals
that is what makes America itself so
make sure you love that and I if you do
I'm I'm thrilled I love your honesty in
saying that actually I do because we got
to call it out that's what it is I'll
give you that and I'll also say that
there are obviously things about the
culture of my country country which
Americans find inexplicable too right so
I get it it's you know I've been down
this road many times because I take it
very I don't know viscerally I think
when I see these massacres I just I hate
seeing them especially be the school
shootings as as a human being my
visceral reaction is and it's the old
Einstein you know in Reverse really it's
like the the idea to me of total
insanity is that you do nothing and
nothing and nothing and nothing expect a
different result but you're assuming
that that was the purpose of the thing
in the first place it was a very
different purpose I totally agree the
purpose was keeping the government at
Bay I know but I don't think that's
what's now behind all these mass
shootings I think it's a different but
but there you're smart guy like so I
think I want to just track something you
said your response to what happened in
the aftermath of
911 I think you didn't get to fully
completing we went on a different strand
but to complete it I think you were kind
of painting that as a good thing and I
was pointing to the same set of facts
and describing it as a bad thing let me
explain let me explain I was the editor
of a major national newspaper in Britain
which vehemently opposed the Iraq War
and we were the lefter sent a newspaper
that Tony Blair the L Prim Min the Iraq
War you mean opposed the Iraq War yeah
is in Iran no big deal no no Iraq Iraq
Iraq Iraq yeah yes get it right opposed
the Iraq War and uh and I'm very proud
that we I think it was a devastating
mistake fought on the completely false
pretext of Saddam Hussein having weapons
of mass destruction which or having
anything to do with 911 which they lied
about does nothing do with it Li I think
it's a different argument about
Afghanistan and I have listen I have my
brother was a serving British army
officer served in Iraq and Afghanistan
as did my brother-in-laws all the
military my family served alongside
Americans right so uh I have a lot of
vested interest in that um America I
understood the distinction of in that
case clearly Al-Qaeda were using
Afghanistan as a place to plan Terror
attacks against the United States I
understood you have to go and get them
it's not dissimilar actually to what the
argument you're seeing used by Israel
now with Hamas and it's incredibly
difficult and very complicated I don't
know how you go and get terrorists who
are surrounded and embedded with
civilians without killing a lot of
civilians and it's a moral Quagmire
which I don't think anyone can
satisfactorily answer actually there's a
different dimension of this response
that I I was wondering and if you had a
view on I do is the adoption of the
Patriot Act Right the restrictions on
our freedoms spying on our conversations
the idea that somehow because two people
have a telephone conversation but it's a
post 911 era the government can listen
into that without a warrant I reject
that I think those were mistakes and I
think you and I have different worldview
where would does that does if if the
sole question is how many lives are
saved you might come out in one place my
resp if the separate question is what
are our founding principles of who we
are in this country you come out in a
different place and so whether it's the
first amendment or the Second Amendment
or in that case the fourth amendment I
think that whether or not you want to
have different views the only thing I
would say is I want more people loving
the United States of America but I'd
rather at least most people know the
United States
and deci they dise with it to think they
it but realize that actual is they
imaged I person think the radicalism of
the American Revolution is a beautiful
thing that's how I think we're going to
unite this country but it's not going to
be at pretending that those are moderate
ideals because they're not okay tell me
who wrote this after January the 6th it
was a dark day for democracy the loser
of the last election refused to concede
the race claim the election was stolen
raised hundreds of millions of dollars
from loyal supporters and is considering
running for executive office again I'm
referring of course to Donald Trump I
wrote those words in my book in the same
ju position to Stacy Abrams filling that
you stand by them so look I think that
here's what you went on to say Trump
delivered another tale of grievance here
no one likes a s loser one of the worst
victimhood complexes of all said his
claims about the election were weak so
here's my point what he did was
downright abhorent do you I mean do you
stand by all that stuff you said about
Trump and January 6 the reason I have a
different View today is that they have
been going after him so there's a time
and place to say something okay I tend
to not say what everybody else is saying
at the time and part of the reason is
what needs to be said needs to be said
when it's hard not when it's easy but I
think you were right to said at the time
I said the same thing I fell out with
him over at the time so so I would have
I would have done things very
differently I would have done things
dramatically differently and I will note
to you I'm running for president in the
same election As Trump but against the
backdr of him not being prosecuted for
this I think it's I take the other side
of this to you don't think you have the
election stolen well I think that to
tell you the truth where the election
stolen it was stolen in a different
sense of the word and we can go into
this if you want big Tech Google and
other search algorithms and the a very
interesting point I think that that's
that's really where the real issue is as
I said to him when I interviewed him I
said you're fighting the wrong stol
election claim what do you mean I said
Well when the New York Post story
exposing Hunter Biden's laptop that was
the real issue that when that was
basically vaporized by big Tech yeah to
protect the bidens and R and you and I
both look at the same polls those would
have changed the result of the election
could have ch so there's evidence of a
potential election so on that I kind of
agree yeah that's that's what I've said
all along here's would say that's not
the position he takes well it's fine and
we are allowed to have different
positions my position also is the 2016
election was the real election that was
decisively stolen from Trump the one
that he won for sure decisively every
agrees he W because he wasn't allowed to
govern with an impeachment in how are
you going to be every time he gets
indicted it's quite extraordinary
situation I think these these politici
if I just finish my thought let meish
question indictments are wrong okay all
of them I think all of them so far are
wrong his mother Theresa I don't say
he's Mother Theresa but he's not a
criminal so nearly a hundred criminal
charges they're all baseless so the ones
I've read I mean those are four
indictments we're talking about I read
each one thoroughly okay okay each one
is using each one is using a novel legal
Theory so so even innocent assumes that
the thing that's even being alleged was
you genuinely believe he's innocent of
everything he's been charged with I
think we can talk through each one and I
yes I believe the answer is innocent
because the legal fiction of the charges
themselves elves are made up
interpretations of the law that have
never been used in this country how are
you going to beat him by convincing
voters that I have fresh legs I am from
a different generation and we're in the
middle of a war in this country and I do
believe that we're in the middle of a
war between those of us who love this
country and are founding ideals but
Trump loves the country and we're all on
the same side of this war right we're
all Trump myself Etc I even think many
Independents and Democrats are on the
side of this war those of us who love
this country and are founding ideals and
a fringe minority and I do believe it's
a fringe minority
who hate this country and are founding
ideals that's the real div and so how am
I going to beat him how am I going to
beat the rest of the Republican field
the question is who is the right General
to now lead us to victory in that war
well here's one of the tricks half the
people on the other side of that war
pece are people younger than me who
never learned those ideals in the first
place we can bring them along too now
we're talking about somebody who has not
been wounded in that War I have fresh
legs I am 38 years old 5 years older
than Thomas Jefferson was when he wrote
the Declaration of Independence but less
than half the age of the other people
who were running many of them so I
believe I have an ability to take our
America First agenda to the next level
and honest to God I would love Trump as
an adviser as a mentor telling me
exactly where the bodies are buried in
the administrative state or otherwise to
be able to go further he rolled that log
over we saw what crawled out I'm bring
the P VP I've Tau him as a mentor I
don't think he would take the VP job
although I haven't asked him I'll keep
it on the list but I think that you
tempted to R highly unlikely that you T
to run out and commit a lot of crimes to
get indictments to get your poll numbers
up I'm not going to do
that I'm going to wrap up very soon just
a few little quick on and and the truth
is Pierce I just think it's really
important that again
you understand this I think you
understand I'm not mean to be preachy
but there is a difference between making
a bad judgment and committing a crime
and I think it is a danger to our
Liberty I'm not saying conflate those
way I'm not saying it's a criminal and
have you read those indictments
extraordinary of Affairs where someone
can face that volume of criminal
indictments and his poll numbers keep
going up I mean in England that
candidate would be dead and buried after
the first barrage of them right however
unfair they may be that's on the
politics of it I think that the reality
is the opposite here is the fact that
all of these indictments are coming at
the same time right as he's running for
office using novel legal theories that
have never been proc lot I think a lot
of that has has Merit has to do with the
fact that he's running I think they're
over egging the sule as I would say the
opposition
I think they're they're just determined
one way or another hang out Trump you
ever talked to I've talked to him a few
times when was the last time it's been a
while yeah probably before the first
debate easily yeah do you think he
should is he being bit gutless not
getting on that stage I think as long as
he's this far ahead I kind of get it but
I hope that we have a chance to have
open discourse in this race but you know
it's like you're the NBA Playoffs the
team that's you know number one by a
stretch gets a buy you know we're about
to have the third debate I know I'm
focused on making sure that I'm the
clear second before I think you're a
great energizing force in the race I've
said this to you from the very start
I've interviewed you in much shorter
context many times but we've sparred
we've had our fun but I like it and also
I think you you get out there and you
put yourself in the L's Den which I
respect I do respect it and I had to say
we haven't really got into it but all
the woke Madness stuff you've been
absolutely Rock Solid on and I
completely agree with you I appreciate
you saying that the thing is and this
also about me is related one of the
other questions you were asking I wrote
the book woke in back when it would
actually was a risk to write that book
yes you did now the reason I I don't I
mean I share all the same beliefs but I
don't talk about it as much
because I mean any Tom Dick and Harry
can go criticize wokeness today right
it's the new popular thing to do it's
almost what the cool kids are doing the
people who are doing it today were the
people who are too afraid to do it in 20
I think what I I absolutely respect
about you saw the dangers of it and you
saw that it was becoming under the guise
of liberalism it was becoming a new form
of fascism and I I think you served a
valuable Public Service in blowing that
lad up and I I feel it's beginning to
turn I I think it is too the majority of
people are just sick and tired of it
well I think I think this election makes
a big difference in that result just in
terms of not even the laws we passed
there's some element of that but just
the tone of national character that we
set in the country because if you think
about what allows you know wokeness or
anything like it to to
Fester it's a deeper generational hunger
for purpose and meaning and I think it's
been a long time since we've had
president that has revived and spoken to
our national character and that's half
the job I mean if people Grill on
policies that's just half the job the
other half of the job is do you have an
understanding of what our national
character is and then can you actually
bring it back well let me ask you about
your character for young people were
able to do that let me ask you about
your character very quickly how how rich
are you VAR by depending on the stock
market you know uh billion on a good day
and uh you know maybe 600 million on a
bad day but U US Dollars yeah yeah a
billion on a good day yeah maybe a
little more on a good day yeah do you
like being a billionaire I don't
particularly relish the title I am not
one of these people that that's been a
life achievement of mine I I'm thrilled
that this country allowed me to achieve
everything that I have I'm proud of my
accomplishments I don't apologize for
success but I also don't fetishize green
pieces of paper I think sometimes it's
something that leads people to deep
unhappiness and I've been around a lot
of them and I'm careful to make sure I
don't become one of them either we we
try to live in a way that you maybe
would reflect a fraction of that net
worth in a way that actually hopefully
allows our family to avoid some of the
traps that some of my wealthier friends
have fallen into your wife aova I think
is how she pronounced it she said your
two best qualities were your joy and
optimism is that what she said that's
nice of her what do you think of that is
that that true yeah I think I'm I'm a
naturally a very optimistic person it's
funny she says that because she's the
person who experiences my crankiness the
most at times but but there's a joy and
optimism in there on certain days it's
buried more deeply than others when was
the moment you knew she was the one for
you we were hiking a mountain in it was
a Flatt top mountain in Colorado we were
in uh Rocky Mountain National Park and
she was the one who was beating me all
the way up the hiking trail she had
actually done kilamanjaro not long
before that but we were we were going
pretty hardcore to the top I had been
there to the top before and I wanted to
show it to her and it was just the final
maybe three 00 ft 200 feet to the to the
top but there was a massive snowstorm
that set in and she's somebody who's
made it to the tops of these mountains
before I said I was going to go and
wanted to wanted to you know make sure
we saw that through and she grabbed my
hand and said we're going to come back
and do this sometime in the future but
we're going to have a long future
together and we turned around and we
made it all the way back down that
mountain and and knew and here we are
yeah how did you propose I proposed it
was actually uh you know the the real
story I mean the cake was baked long
before I proposed I think that we wanted
to get to a place where both of our
families were all there we knew we knew
what the destination was going to be and
uh yeah I haven't told the story before
but she she sort of said all right all
right like at this point I don't really
care about the ring or anything else if
you don't get on this you might find me
proposing to you un let's just get this
over with so I got a uh so I was you
know put the perfect ring plans to one
side and we got a little Ring Pop and we
did it in the streets of New York City a
ring pop what's that it's like a little
lollipop as a ring it's like a big Ruby
you gave your wife a lollipop ring she
was thrilled with it and you're a
billionaire man what were you thinking
yeah I wasn't at the time you know was
working my way up but uh but we got her
her uh did you at least go her red ruby
ring to follow though did you go on
bended knee I did oh yeah yeah we we
went through the whole thing on bended
KNE oh yeah yeah we did with your
lollipop ring with with the lollipop
ring yeah it was in a nice case though
it was in a very nice case and what is
finally what what is the secret to to
married life
oh I think we um practice actually is is
is a good way to look at it I think that
if you look at every iteration as a
round of practice then that presumes
that you're on the same page about the
destination you're just iterating and
practicing to to you know get
to the per the version of perfection and
so it's never perfect but it's about the
pursuit of perfection and romance are
you a romantic guy I I I maybe on a good
day yeah what the most romantic thing
you've ever done I don't know what I
can't I can't profess on my own self-
romantic thing
I don't know I feel like a little bit uh
I'm not I'm not a guy who's going to Pat
I could think of some examples right now
but I'm not it's not the kind of thing
that I want to give me a little bone you
know I think romantic bone I think that
it was um maybe one of our I I don't
know how pora felt about it but our our
Valentine's Day gift she's she's a tough
one to please because she's not really
into uh you know stuff she's not a she
has stuff she's not particularly into
stuff but I thought about what I could
do that that was better than her which
are few and far between but I gave her a
tennis lesson and we actually and we
actually and we actually went through it
and she's naturally athletic person but
we picked something up that we were then
able to do together for a while really
yeah so I know it's a small thing I
don't know but there's no big ceremony
around it I get that yeah it's a nice
thing yeah and she and she loves it she
seemed to like it yeah who wins I mean I
it's the sport I've played since growing
up she's a better volleyball player
that's what she played so you basically
got her to play something you knew you
could beat her at I had to pick
something had to find something she
usually has me beat out is that
basically your character at a nutshell
you know it's interesting I'd have to do
some Freudian introspection for that one
this might that might have been the
toughest gacha of the whole interview
the whole thing was leading to that it's
good to see you it's good to seeing you
man I appreciate it yeah I enjoyed it
thanks very much thank you
man